That'd be good.
It's the right ask you use
your content creator car.
The instructor I Dang,
I love have you tried to eat natural
cause he has a mission is by educating
developers to build Ai.
He's also a dad and an entrepreneur,
founder of a crowd funding platform
for developers called Harvey. Uh,
he developed Ios apps
and then has a host of open source work
sites that you like to travel musician
who was Morton and scuba diver.
And then I was like
tempted to say hello world.
I think I'll need that
again.
Welcome.
All right.
Hi everybody. All right.
Testing for eight, seven, six.
That's the next code for Bitcoin. So buy
it at that price. I'm just kidding. Okay.
Uh, yeah, yeah. You know the,
the end of that description was like
this really old description that O'Reilly
wrote when I wrote the book decentralized
applications like four years ago,
which at the time Havi was
yes, a crowdsourcing platform
that I helped create,
but now it's deprecated it et cetera.
You know how stuff moves in software.
It's just like hearing God and
like 30 seconds. But, uh, yeah,
so this talk is called decentralized.
Let me move out the way.
Let me just get a feel for how
this is going to work. Okay.
Decentralize artificial intelligence.
That's the name of this dog.
It's really combining two
technologies that are very hot today.
Deep learning and blockchain. We know
about these two technologies, right?
Even if you're a data science,
you studied blockchain at at some point
it's articles. It's, it's hard not to,
to look at this space with some,
some level of interest.
So we're going to talk about how to
combine these two technologies together to
make something beautiful.
So I want to start with a quote by
a very well known public figure,
or shall we say
the quote,
is he alone?
Who owns the youth games for the future?
And this is by Adolf Hitler.
I just want you to think about
this quote for a second. He alone,
who owns the youth? The gains, the
future. What did he mean by that?
Clearly he knew what he was talking about.
He was able to influence the youth to
kill people by the hundreds of thousands.
So I want to ask you guys this question.
Who owns the youth?
Single word answers is an open question.
You can raise your hand once a youth.
Yeah. Facebook. Okay.
Really Smart Guy. Any other,
any other, um, snapchat. Okay. You
guys know what's up. Yeah. Yeah,
exactly. Um, yeah. Facebook,
snapchat, those are, those are
some possible answers. But let's,
let's talk about what the, what the
larger answer to this question is.
Who owns the youth?
Who owns the future?
So in the 80s, the web was
created, et Cetera, et Cetera,
or ride the worldwide web of, you know,
we, we, we know that the web was created,
but I remember going to,
Sir sir, I was in Geneva,
had to talk him at cern in Geneva and
it was amazing. Like the data scientist,
they're like, we were getting
so technical, they knew
exactly what was going on.
Their questions were so beautifully
orchestrated. They were challenging me.
It was amazing. It was people, I mean, the
amount of data that cern has is amazing.
Like, anyway, that's a
tangent. When I was at cern,
I remember seeing Tim
Berners Lee's office,
the creator of http hypertext transfer
protocol for the worldwide web.
Arguably without that protocol,
everything that we're doing, carousel,
everything about the web wouldn't exist.
And I remember seeing his office and just
standing there for a second and being
like, wow, this is where it all began.
And then I backed up for a second.
There was just like, oh my God and all
these kids are coming in. I was like,
oh I bet I bet her backup.
And these kids started coming in in
mass and they were like, I dunno,
eight to eight or 10 years old.
It was like a school field trip.
And they came in and they saw
and then the teacher was like,
or the guidance and this is where
the world wide web was created.
And the kids were like, oh my God. And
they took a snapchat and immediately left.
Like they didn't even like some
of the kids just when they,
one of them when the guide said
that they just got and kept walking.
So that's who wants a future snapchat,
right?
Cause it gets you snapchat.
That was web 1.0
this man is web 2.0
who knows who this guy is?
Just shout it out. Jeff Bezos,
who is the richest guy in the
world right now. Jeff basis. Yeah.
In 98 this was Jeff basis.
He was selling books.
That's all he wanted to do with
amazon.com it was selling books in a very,
very small office. His office
was just a desk, right?
And now Amazon is more
powerful than Walmart.
It's market cap is higher than Walmart.
It's market cap is higher than any book
seller in the world. Barnes and nobles,
et Cetera. All of these global
brands, Amazon eats them up literally.
Quite literally.
Amazon acquires them.
So Jeff Bezos owns Amazon. He, so
he's the largest shareholder in Amazon
and Amazon is just one example.
We've got snapchat, we've got Google,
we've got Facebook.
And these entities that we've created
over time have been a result of
entrepreneurs saying, how do we take web
1.0 and how do we capitalize off of it?
How do we create something where we
can make money off of it, which is,
it makes sense,
right?
This is a beautiful technology and the
initial aims for the web were beautiful.
They were very pure.
Let's take this decentralized Internet
that Tim Berners Lee helped create and
let's create services on top of it, right?
So let's, let's let me take the server.
Right? And it started having, you know,
all of these computers talk to each other,
which was very hard to do at the time.
Let me just make one central server,
let me make, let me use this to
http protocol to create this,
get and sets transfer and store all of
that data on the central server like
that. Right? And it made it easy
to do things like have an Amazon,
have an Ebay, have a marketplace
that was social network,
have a ride sharing service.
All this stuff that we use today is
because we were able to create these
centralized services, it worked really
well and there were no problems. In fact,
it was a faster way to do things,
right? It was a faster way.
And it was a more efficient way.
It just worked,
but what's happened now is really bad.
Objectively speaking,
this is not my opinion. It
is objective Lee, a bad fit,
and this is not just coming from me. This
is coming from the creators of the web.
Tim Berners, Lee, Jerome Linear,
the pioneers of the Internet don't
like what has happened today,
what the Internet has become.
How do we fix this?
What does web 3.0 look like not web 1.0
or 2.0 not having centralized services
but decentralized services.
What the web,
the original vision for the web
was to have decentralized services
in a good economy.
We monetize more and more,
but in a bad economy we
monetize less than less.
What is the most valuable
resource we have today?
Can anyone answer that question?
What is the most valuable
resource at any person has today?
Yes? Another word for knowledge
is data. Data. Exactly,
but what are we doing
with our data right now?
We are giving it away for free in return
for a free service. Right? That's,
that's a part of the terms of use for
all of these services. We use Facebook,
Facebook's terms of service,
snapchat, Internet service.
You let us use your data.
We can learn from your data.
We can profit off of your data.
We can sell your data, and in return
we'll let you use a service. That's fine,
right?
It works.
But what's happened is this is shrinking
the economy because all of that data is
being concentrated in the central servers.
He's connected courts that
everybody has a connector, right?
These are gateways for the wet.
We need that data because as automation
technology gets better and better as we
learn to automate all of these things,
the only agency,
the only power you're going to have
in this new world that we're very fast
moving to is your data, but right
now you're giving it away for free.
So what value do you bring to the world
when you don't own your data? Nothing.
Zero. You have no value. If you give
away your data, you have no value.
So you need to own your data and
profit from your data, right?
This is a kin to something
like a basic income.
When robotics and automation technology
and AI and deep learning and machine
learning, when all of that gets good
enough in the next five to 10 years,
probably everything will be automated.
Everything.
Everything that can be
automated will be automated.
I just made that up on the spot.
You call it my loan.
There's accountability as well.
Okay,
so accountability is we don't know what
they're doing with our data. Right?
First of all, we want to own our data.
We want to profit off of our data.
Right now we're giving it away for free
and they're doing something with it that
we don't even know what it is.
They don't have to tell us. Right.
They don't have to tell us what
they're doing with the data.
They could give it away to governments.
They could use to spy on people.
I was having a conversation with
a friend a few days ago. Okay.
We were talking about something,
a single topic later on on
her phone in the ad it said,
the topic that we were talking about,
they are listening on our phones.
They are listening in real time.
Facebook is listening. Our phones,
they're listening to us.
They are using that data because there
are no checks and balances. That's just,
that's just what's happened. There are
so powerful. They're all around us.
The Internet of things is really a
set of spy devices for these central
authorities and last week we are trying
to solve AI and I'm going to talk about
that at the very,
very end,
but we're trying to solve AI and we need
a way to do that and this is how we do
that. All of these problems are
shrinking economy, data, ownership,
accountability and towards
general intelligence.
All events can be sold if we moved to
web 3.0 so you guys wouldn't with me like
we need to move to web 3.0 rights.
This is the, this is the plan.
How do we do this? So I'm going
to tell you how to do this. Okay,
I'm going to tell you how to do this.
I'm going to show you right now.
How did you, you ready? Okay. There we
go. It all starts with something very,
very simple.
The link list. Oh, here at saint
the link list before. Awesome. Yeah.
Okay, so the link list is a
very, very simple data structure.
I've got the code for it right here.
Don't worry if you've never coded before,
don't worry about it. It's only
you know, 12 lines of code,
12 single lines in python.
And what this does is it creates a
data structure called a linked list.
And a link list is just a very simple
object that's linked to the next object
that's linked to the next object
that's linked to the next object.
And it just goes on it. But as much as
you want. And we can make one in python,
we'll just say class node. This is
a class, this thing, this square,
and let's say, let's give it
some functions. Get data. Okay.
That's going to give us
what's inside of here,
which is if we could store
it the word hello, get next,
get the next note in the list.
Stack sent data.
What do I want to put in this thing?
Hello. A number on an image or video,
whatever data and set next one's gonna
be the the data and the next link to the
next note in the link list.
That's it is a simple data structure.
This is going to help us move towards
web 3.0 you might be thinking,
wait a second.
No,
this has been around since the 80s how
is this going to help me with anything?
So let's take this link list.
Let's,
let's take this linguist and let store
a copy of it on let's say a million
computers. Let's just say, hey
guys, I've got this link list.
I want you to store a copy of it.
And inside of this link list,
we're not going to store the word
Holo APP does nothing for us.
What's instead store I transaction
and not just one transaction,
several transactions, in fact, millions
of transactions between people payments.
Let's store that and let's try to make
it so that no one can modify this linked
list. No one can change the transactions
in this link list. How do we do that?
Okay.
What if we had a separate system of
people and all they did was they solved
random mathematical
problems with our computer,
and this required a lot of
computing power, like a lot.
So much so that in order for you to be
able to change any of the data in any of
these nodes,
you would have to have more than 50%
of the computing power of all of those
notes that are solving these
random mathematical problems. Now,
what if the amount of computing power
in those notes was greater than the 500
fastest supercomputers
in the world combined?
Well then you would have to have more
computing power and the 500 fastest
supercomputers in the world combined to
change this, the data in this link list.
What that means is no one could
change the data in this link list.
So if we did that,
we had a link list that everybody sorted
a copy of that no one could change the
data in.
We would call it a blockchain.
And that's what the Bitcoin blockchain is.
It's a glorified linked list. That's
it. It's a glorified link list.
And instead of calling them links
or notes, we call them blocks.
And the reason it's called a chain is
because it's not just pointing to a random
node with the word hello in it.
It's pointing to a random node with
transactions in it and the reason that the
transactions are stored as his
tree decision tree to be specific,
we can call it a Merkle Dag as well.
We don't have to talk about
that is because that's just
a more efficient way of
storing and retrieving from it.
But you can just think of it at an
abstract level as just the list of
transactions.
And that's a blockchain.
So this is a very new idea, right?
This, this was you know, eight nine,
10 years ago when Satoshi
invented this, this, this concept,
it was the first time where we could say,
I'm going to store my transactions
in this data structure.
That's what the blockchain is.
It's a data structure.
I'm going to store my data and this
thing and no one's going to be able to
modify those transactions.
That's why we use banks, right?
There are only a few real banks in the
world that we trust enough to store our
money in our,
you know,
something very valuable because we
trust that they're not gonna modify
essentially the,
the list of transactions in our account.
They're not going to modify it.
They're going to say,
this is the amount you had before and
this is the amount you have now. Trust us.
Right? And that's it. We trust them.
But what if we could store our money in
a way that we didn't have to trust the
bank so there's not a third party.
This is the first time that we've
ever been able to do that. The,
in the advent of this data structure.
Right. That's cool. Okay. Okay.
We don't need a bank. Great. So what,
what else could we store this
thing besides transactions?
We don't need a trusted third
party to store our transactions.
We don't need to trust a
third party to store our data.
third party to store our code.
What about our web apps?
What about our apps like
snapchat and Facebook and Google?
What if we could store code in this thing,
not just transactions.
And that is what the theory is. Blockchain
is they took bitcoin's blockchain,
the added a bunch of other data
like logs, difficulty, timestamps,
mixes. But really what
matters is this, the code,
you don't just the store transactions in
the ethereum blockchain, you store code.
What that means is every computer,
every note,
remember it's a glorified link clicks.
Every node in the network is storing
coat instead of pushing code to a single
server like Heroku, right? That's
how we usually build web apps.
We store it on a single node
that everybody has to agree upon.
So in order to modify that code,
you would have to have more computing
power than the 500 fastest supercomputers
in the world combined.
So this is a trustless way to build web
apps and that's how we're going to get
to web 3.0 so what does code
on a theory I'm look like?
Go back
this,
this 17 line of code snippet is what
you would call an initial coin offering.
17 lines of code is responsible
for raising more money.
And the past two years that I've been
raised by every IPO in the past 10 we're
talking about more than a hundred
billion US dollars worth of,
of investments from the public,
the public,
every ICO that you're seeing
these days is a result of this.
Someone takes this as a variable
that says how many, you know,
shares or coins or tokens do I want and
how much do I want to sell those tokens
for? They take this code and they push
it to the ethereum blockchain via a push
command in terminal or they can do it
via a web app and then they have this
public address, you know, 25
characters or core more and they say,
here's the address, ICO time invest.
And then people just, you know,
30 million in a single day.
This is kind of stuff happens.
This is very powerful and
no one controls this, right?
This is the advent of a new structure,
similar to a corporation,
a new type of institution that no one,
no one controls.
And we can do this with the
ethereum blockchain because
we don't have to trust a
third party, not just a bank, but
even the government legal documents,
things like that. We can build these
with smart contracts things every,
every time. We'd had to require
to trust the third party.
We can remove that and push that
instead in the form of contracts to the
ethereum blockchain.
There's a problem though,
so
if you think about, okay, well I'm going
to make a web app and it's going to,
it's going to pull from the weather.com
Api and it's just going to tell you the
weather. That's it. Okay, so
it's called my weather app,
decentralized.com and all of
this places a single text.
The weather today in Singapore,
and it pulls that data from weather.com
is Api with the parameter of Singapore.
Now it returns the result and a displays
that, right, whatever degrees Celsius.
If we were to do that on the ethereum
blockchain, it wouldn't work. Why?
Because every single node in the network
has to pull back that data at the same
time, right? Because they're all
executing that code at the same time.
But what the weather changes over time,
right?
So they would all have to agree upon
the time. How do you do that? You can't,
right?
So the solution to this is to have what's
called an oracle and the oracle is a
trusted third party source that speaks
to the web that the ethereum blockchain
can pull from. So you might be
thinking, wait a second, okay,
I thought this was trustless. What does,
what does it deal with this oracle thing?
There are networks of Oracle's out there,
you know,
delegations four or five of them and
they can all agree, a crew agree on,
they can have consensus on some data,
but this is a solution to pulling data
from the, from the web 2.0 in the,
in the form of API APIs until
we have a better solution.
But that's how it works right now.
So you might be thinking,
okay,
we can have our application level
constructs on the ethereum blockchain,
we can pull data in the form
of oracles from the web.
But then how do we store like huge
databases onto the blockchain?
Could we do that? I mean you could
technically, but then every minor,
everyone who's downloading a copy of this
blockchain within have to store all of
that data on their personal computer.
Facebook has a lot of data.
If we were in a decentralized Facebook
and say this is the authority on version
of Facebook,
everybody would have to store a copy
of Facebook that's just infeasible.
So what we need, it's not just a, an
application level construct that says,
here are usernames here, your
tweets here, you know, et cetera.
We needed to point to some kind
of decentralized data store,
a storage for data that is
not owned by anyone. Now,
the best solution for this that I've
found is called the interplanetary file
system. So high PFS is big. There's a,
there's a lot to go into about IPFS.
Um, it's, it's, it's, it's a
beautiful system the way it works,
but essentially it's a group of
computers that all agree on some data.
So if I want to push some data
to Google cloud or AWS right now,
right? The services owned that data,
right? So I would say, you know,
I've got some huge video,
let me push it to Google cloud or AWS,
and they would store it.
How do we be centralized that with IPFS,
it's a network of computers who are
saying, I'm an IPFS snowed, right?
When you pushed that video to IPFS,
they not everybody's stores a copy of
that video. One person will for our copy,
that video will be split up into several
parts and replicated across the network.
So then you might be thinking, well,
what if someone deletes their node? Well,
there's already replications everywhere.
How are these nodes incentivized? Well,
there's this idea of file coin where
these nodes or pay to store this data.
So it's how to incentivize these notes.
So that's kind of our complete list of
solutions for this web 3.0 we can have a
data store called IPFS.
We can have etherium to store code and
application level constructs and Oracle's
to pull data from the web. This
is, this is how web 3.0 works.
This is the new stack.
So this is how it works, right? If
you're a young references content,
big data that's stored on IPFS,
it gets that static content.
That distributed application gets that
content from IPFS and it gets the global
state or theory. It's, it's
a global state machine,
so if we combine IPFS and Ethereum,
we can build these distributed
decentralized applications. Right,
but what's a talk?
What is,
what is really a talk without
talking about deep learning, right?
Deep learning is where it's at.
We've got this thing called a
neuron in our brain theirselves.
Billions of these cells in our
brain and they make us intelligence.
They give us consciousness and
love and emotion, all these things.
We feel it because of this thing.
It's a collection of them.
I don't know how they work.
You go to do you either.
There's nobody needs is the most
renowned neuroscientists in the world.
No one knows how this thing works,
but in the 50s some guy was like,
I mean I get the basic idea. There is some
data that's being fed into this thing.
Something's happening here and then
it sends it out and then very roughly,
very, very roughly. He
created a mathematical model
for this thing. He says,
he said, we have these inputs. Let
me just take this, these inputs,
these are a set of numbers. Let me
apply some kind of summation to this.
And then some kind of
nonlinear entity as in, um,
let me take this data
and make sure that it,
it can learn a function that
can learn any type of function,
both the linear and a nonlinear function
that means any type of function.
And then I'll put a result, right? So it
takes some data, it does something to it.
And then it outputs that data.
And what happens here has been the topic
of debate amongst many researchers,
like what do we do to
it? But the, but the,
but the idea is the same as
when we take some input data,
apply some kind of function to it,
and then we have an output and then we
change these things together. So we got,
we have a lot of [inaudible]. And what
happened is the deep learning revolution,
right? All of these things that humans
are good at. Image recognition, uh,
driving cars, et Cetera, all
these things. For some reason,
this model that resembles
the human brain works well,
sometimes even better than we do. So
this is kind of, this is mind boggling,
right? On silicon, these chips,
we roughly estimated the,
the rules that are happening here and
it's doing something that even humans
can't even do.
Could there be some universal law of
intelligence out there that we're just
slowly approximating, that we're
just slowly coming close to probably.
And this is our first step there.
Deep Learning, incredible technology.
Okay, so how do we combine
all three of these things?
How do we combine IPFS if
theory in department? Well,
there's one really great example that
I know of called the open mind that a
friend of mine has built with his
community. But the idea is this.
If I'm a data scientist
and you have some data,
if I want to train my deep
learning model on your data,
how do I do that in a way that involves
no third party where you don't have to
trust me that I'm going to look at
your data. Say it's very sensitive,
like patient data,
like for hospital records.
How do I train my model
to learn from your data?
So I can make predictions about say cancer
or some other disease without looking
at your personal information.
So this is a perfect example of how
you can put these three technologies
together. You can have IPFS store
that data. You can have a theory,
build an application level construct
for smart contracts so that the data
doesn't have to be stored
on a central server.
And you could use deep learning
to learn from that data.
So if you want to know how all three of
these can work together and look up open
minds, the website is open mind
dot. Uh, but it's, uh, it's a,
it's a great example of how
to combine all these three,
these three things together.
Yeah.
So where does this lead
us? Eventually? This is a,
this is a graph of emergent,
higher level complexity,
simple AI agents that are answered,
but complex warm behavior emerges.
Right now we have AI and they live
on servers. They live in our phones,
they live on laptops,
but if we could free these AI's from
the confines of servers and let and let
them live in a decentralized space,
they could speak to each other,
they could learn from each other,
and perhaps the real solution to higher
level intelligence is to let that
complexity emerge rather
than trying to coat it in.
Why don't we just let it emerge, right?
We don't know how consciousness works,
but we have this basic
rough idea of how it works.
What if we just need to give it
enough complexity and what that real
intelligence emerge,
we just can't even understand it.
That is very likely the case. And if we
use blockchains and we use it theory, I'm,
when we use IPFS and all
of these decentralized
technologies we can create real
artificial intelligence is that are
as smart if not hundred thousand times
smarter than all of us.
Lastly,
you might be thinking, why would we want
to do that? Why do I care about that?
Right? Water crisis sees the
spread of infectious diseases,
weapons of mass destruction,
North Korea,
Donald from interstate conflict, failure
of climate change, adaption, energy,
price shock, fiscal crisis is
unemployment. Biodiversity,
Watson ecosystem collapse would say,
well,
it's too late for us to solve
climate change. It's too
late. No matter what we do,
we're not going to solve it. We
are. We are headed for destruction.
We are headed for complete Libyan. There
is nothing we can do. We're screwed.
I don't think so because those people
don't know about the power of Ai,
right? If we solve Ai,
let's just say we solve it,
we create an intelligence that's as smart,
if not smarter than all of us.
We can give it an objective,
a goal, a function,
and that objective could
be solve climate change.
It would look at data in a way no human
ever could in a way that 10,000 plus
scientists put together in a room
for a hundred years couldn't solve.
It could fall all of
these things immediately.
It could move us towards this utopia that
we didn't think even possible before.
If we do it the right way and if all of
us together are thinking about ways to
do this, we all have to be thinking about
how these technologies work together.
If you even barely understand
how this technology works,
it is your responsibility to do something
about it because there are millions of
people across the world.
We don't even have food and water
rights efficient [inaudible] in Maslow's
hierarchy of these,
they don't have any of these things.
How can they come to these
kinds of insights? They
cant everybody in this room.
It's your responsibility to
do, to, to work on this, to,
to help make this happen.
How do you do that? You, you
learned from the Internet.
You use this new inner university that
we have is collective university to teach
yourself to educate yourself on how these
technologies work and how you can best
influence the problems in our
world using these technologies.
So I want to leave you
with a single remark,
solve AI or die trying.
That's my motto.
That's what I live by and if you want to
learn more, there's my youtube channel.
Subscribe.
Thank you very much.
Okay. Yes. Uh, we have in this community,
so anybody have any questions?
Okay.
The example that you follow,
right? That we can have,
it became a peculiar dot back to fund
that the Algorithm be why not the act?
The thing that I can be a
little holiday [inaudible] yeah.
Security is definitely an issue we have
to solve when it comes to decentralized
applications.
One of the reasons that we centralized
stuff was because one person could just
secure everything, right? It's much more
secure to have data on a central server.
So to is one
really,
really great area to focus on if you're
looking on something to work on as one
of those looping fields.
There was so much a startup could
do their distributed security,
the centralized security in terms of
a solution right now for security in
general for decentralized applications,
uh,
one thing could be better ways of
storing data that's involved replication.
So replication is one example,
right?
A lot of times data is just lost and
IPFS or something like it's just lost
because there's not enough replication.
So looking at different ways,
different algorithm for
replicating data that our edition,
that would be a great
way to solve security
that could have taught the update.
They do know ain't nobody can modify it,
but if you want to provide that,
they would be on me that they
were due by
Dave or David.
But if I want to pick your of the lead
actor that twill or other eye maybe gated
or that day,
that cannot really act as the
medium ones any for why are we have,
we definitely have to build an extra
security layer layer on top of it,
like their,
their ideas within these communities
for ipms sanitarium for security layers.
But we would need a different protocol
and entire loan. Like one of these issues,
one of the ways that this
springs up his identity, right?
We don't know who you are.
We don't know how to authenticate you
identity protocols as a layer on top of
these data and application
level protocols.
That would be something that's very
necessary. People have tried this.
Microsoft even tried this with one ID.
It didn't work,
but the problem was they weren't
thinking about it the right way.
So you've got to think about it from
a decentralized way. How do I make,
how do we make an identity protocol
that can speak to these other protocols,
it seamlessly. And there's this
idea of cross chain transfers,
atomic swaps from the bitcoin community.
Um,
I think that would be a good
place to look for inspiration.
Uh, hi. I was wondering, will
let us do with skating full, uh,
the full homomorphic encryption
because if I'm not mistaken,
it's lush.
And I'll tell that deep learning,
the deep learning models tends to
view computational halts. Yeah. Yeah.
So, okay, so two questions there. One, uh,
how do we scale homomorphic encryption?
And two,
how do we solve the
problem of deep learning,
being very computationally expensive
that together just the mold
and stuff. Yeah, definitely.
Yeah. You know what it is.
So, uh, so there's this idea of one shot
learning where we learned from one or two
examples. Like if we look at how
humans learn, you give me your,
give me an image of something that I've
never seen before and in two or three
examples I'll be able to classify it.
Whereas with deep learning,
it requires hundreds of thousands if not
millions of images. This is a problem.
This is not even close to how we learn.
I think the best example
of a very data efficient,
deep learning algorithm is it actually
came out of Facebook and he was called
the memory augmented neural network.
So right now we intertwine the processor
with the memory in the neural network.
That's the weight values,
right? Those matrix wait values.
But what if we could separate that memory
into a separate module and it can say,
here's the memory module.
It's just a glorified matrix.
And then we have the wait values.
Well what happened when they train
this thing was it was able to recognize
handwritten digits with only 15 examples.
This was like two years ago.
And then that, that project
didn't get that much attention.
It should have because that
was amazing. I would say, uh,
look at that, that project
as an example, Facebook,
Ai Research Omnia Blot Dataset,
it's going to be the first link on Google,
but more efficient people, any models
is another open field of research.
Okay.
What was willing to drink.
So it was us
to the changes in those of
a different perspective.
So currently for example,
using some of the typical Asian
functions which met them at ease.
If you are, you know, like
see more more. So these guys,
any mathematical evolution such that,
you know,
future perhaps it could be
one just as you do really get,
there'll be a shift in terms
of how we will get a new roof
space.
And then the second questions,
I'm just curious as to, um, you know, I,
these days they have robots that can
jog and he truly like the tone we need.
The,
so in terms of cyber security,
I'm not sure how well it is,
but what if one day it happens to be at
the hands of maybe someone who was extra
monies or terrorists see what example
where we all we do because the weapons,
everything can be don't come to,
and this school was just go,
you know, is my goal blogging
two years, some of the robots,
uh, talking about, um,
humans in a very negative way.
If we see some like the one that has,
I can't remember her name, the lady
who has these others. Yeah. Yeah.
So there was something negative
about the regime, things about human.
So I mean,
what if one day robots like this and
they learn how to manufacture the mass
wrapping of destruction or whichever
way that they can behave by terminates,
for example. I don't know, how would
it be if you come off? You know,
these are good questions.
Good questions.
The first question about different ways
of looking at ads and neural network in
the future
model that we have right now,
this is one of the most exciting areas
of research and all of computer science
right now. How do we evolve the
neural network architecture?
There's this idea of,
well, let me just act more more
layers. Let me change the weights.
Let me add a new type of layer, right?
And these are, these are okay, this works.
But what if we change the entire hardware?
What if we said,
instead of running it on silicon,
let's run it on a quantum processor?
What happens then? There's the, there's
a brand new use, quantum processing.
We don't know. There's this idea in
neuroscience of quantum nano tubules,
that that's the seat of consciousness that
actually lives in multiple dimensions.
Who knows? But there's a lot of
great research in hardware as well.
So if you want to look at really,
really,
really different radical
breakthroughs and neural networks,
I would actually look at the hardware,
the hardware level,
not the algorithmic level.
Onto your second question
about Terminator Ai. So, uh,
some people say that the
Bitcoin blockchain is, uh, some,
some people will say that bitcoin is
one of those systems where you can sell
drugs easily and you can, but it's one of
those systems that is very untraceable,
right? This is not true. Bitcoin is
the most traceable system in the world.
Key examples, Silk Road, right?
The founder of Silk Road,
every single transaction is stored
in a public way that everyone can,
can view, right? They can
view it, they can validate it,
they can see exactly the trail of
transactions. Now, what happened?
What happens if we take these transactions
and instead we abstract them to two
actions in a network.
This person likes this tweet.
This person did this with this money,
this person launched this nuke,
right? If we put everything onto this
public ledger that everyone can view,
that's a way to democratize,
read access to actions by everyone.
So if there was some kind of
governments ride, for example,
probably the Singaporean government,
we would do something like this cause
they're awesome. Where are they said,
let me just make everything public
and viewable by people right?
Then every politician would have to
record all their transactions on a
blockchain, right? There would
be no more, uh, there were,
there would be much less corruption.
There would be much less. Right.
Because this thing,
this would,
this would be validated by everybody
when it comes to nuclear weapons,
weapons of mass destruction.
If we are able to create these systems
in a way that everyone can verify,
there's more transparency, there would be
less likely of a risk like that. Right.
Because these people would have to be
held accountable and that's really where
this whole blockchain stuff plays in.
It's all about accountability.
Okay.
Do you do that with all the work be done
on that group of stake in blockchain
2.0 there may be a better
technology than in theory coming?
Yeah, I do. I do. I do. There are
some promising blockchains out there.
I think one is, one is
car Dano, right. Um,
Charles Hoskinson was one of the
former founders of etherium and uh,
he's work he's been working on with
that, with, with a really great team.
They're working on KYC compliance as
a way to merge that with the existing
financial infrastructure is great.
I think the idea is that
they have our grades and yes,
there could be something better
than proof of work for sure. I mean,
proof of work is one of those really
computationally expensive processes that
wastes a lot of electricity across the
world that we could put that could be put
to better use. Why have these computers
off random mathematical problems?
Why not instead have them solve protein
folding or some prompts, some, you know,
real problem that matters. So yes, there's
a lot of potential right now. However,
in terms of building something
that affects the population,
that affects consciousness,
that affects culture. If
theory mean, you know, bitcoin,
these are ways of doing that very fast
and then we can update those systems
later on.
We being possible
right now,
he sold me on the Games chess.
You think you would have more practical
problems like four times the other
pacifier one is half deck. You was on
pain in the real world other than yes.
Yeah,
right.
I do. Well, the idea behind reinforcement,
so reinforcement learning has been
around since the 60s it's not new.
All of those concepts that Alphago
used last year, Alphago was a beat.
The best go player in the world will
refresh her and which was a huge deal
because AI experts predicted that it
would take 10 20 years for that to happen.
We did it in a decade less.
All of the components of Alphago,
Monte Carlo tree search,
right, value networks,
policy networks,
neural networks,
these all had all been around for decades.
What was the different steps?
Well,
they just synthesize some ideas that
hadn't been put together and fed it more
computing power than we'd ever
been able to get it before.
And then it gave us this result.
No one thought possible.
So the real breakthrough there was
just giving you a computing power.
There was no difference in
terms of the algorithms,
just a synthesis of old ideas
into one bigger new idea,
which is how most of
research works to be real.
But do I think that we could
do better? For sure, for sure.
I don't see why we aren't thinking of
new ideas for reinforcement learning.
Right?
There's so much we could do in terms
of search strategies for reinforcement
learning.
There's so much we could do when we
combine deep learning and reinforcement
learning together.
Games have been a test bed for AI
because if we can generalize to different
games, maybe we could
generalize to task step matter.
That's why these big institutions
that have been focused on games,
what they're really trying to do is
apply it to real world applications.
Some examples would be
a cooling data centers.
That's what Google did with the same
reinforcement learning algorithm they use
on a game.
They used to reduce the F or increase
the efficiency of cooling their data
centers, but I think it was
40 or 50% which is huge.
That's one example and that's just
because Google did it. Guess what?
Google open source that out rhythm.
If we look on get hub and we see these
reinforcement learning algorithms,
we ourselves can take them and
apply them to some use case, right?
All these researchers at the top
institutions are working on games because
they're trying to improve the
generalization ability. We can, uh,
use it to solve problems today, right?
So we can take those algorithms,
we can use it to solve real problems.
Some avenues like maybe three that I
can think of for reinforcement learning
specifically would be, for
example, traffic control. Uh,
that's a, that's a reinforcement
learning problem, right? Reward, uh,
using an agent to taking a reward and
then cycling that back into the system.
Another one would be,
um,
increasing the efficiency of
bandwidth between applications,
like peer to peer applications. That's
another one for reinforcement learning.
And a third one can just making these up
as I go. A third one would probably be,
uh,
you know how Google did
this with the data center.
We can do that with just lights in
general, right? Energy efficiency.
That would be another one
for reinforcement learning.
All these ideas were,
we were talking about some
event, some timeline, right?
What we are trying to increase
the efficiency of something
that's happening over
time. That's the reinforcement
learning problem, right?
Because it's interacting with a new
environment. It's not an input, output,
static data set. It's a
dynamic environment. So
think about an environment,
thinking about time,
think about sequences and apply
reinforcement learning there.
Yeah, the big one. Last one.
Yes.
Well you mentioned any about how you
get head individual simple on blockchain
and I'll call [inaudible]
and that's the next step.
What have you don't like the emerging,
can't control this one. You didn't write
like entered the column individually.
You know what you do, but you don't
know how to behave in the system.
So what then? That's a great
question. So I met someone,
work on the ethics team.
I did mine and she was telling me that
she was kind of going through this game
with me. Or if she was saying, oh, why
should we release this course card?
Why should we do this?
But the conclusion that she
made me come up come up with,
which is what the conclusion is.
He had already come to the thought process
was that deep mind wanting to be the
first to come up with
the real intelligence.
They wanted to be the first to AI because
they knew that they themselves would
be benevolent with it.
They didn't trust that other people would.
So that's why they didn't open
source it at the time. However,
that's not good for us,
right?
Because if someone at deep mind is
not benevolent for whatever reason,
they could use that AI for evil
by whatever your means of evil.
It's how do we prevent that? The best
way to prevent any kind of malpractice,
any kind of malintent.
It's a democratizes technology to
give it to as many people as possible.
There's a famous quote by,
um, this English playwrights,
Lord acton also by Elon Musk,
but the quote is the best way,
and I'm paraphrasing, the best way
to prevent the rise of a desperate,
someone who is a,
on how all powerful dictator is
to democratize access to power.
If the easiest way is to
centralize that power.
So if we decentralize this power to AI,
to blockchain,
to all this technology
to data specifically,
then we can better increase
the probability or likelihood
that we reach a good
state in the future.
Is there a possibility that someone who
is a bad actor will use this technology?
For sure. I mean, life is full of
existential risks, right? But doing this,
democratizing these,
these technologies further increases
the probability that that won't happen
because we'll come up with some sort of
security system or fail safe or check
system that would prevent
that from happening.
Maybe there's a decentralize
AI that goes rogue. Well,
there might be a decentralized
security system that prevents that,
that someone created beforehand.
We just all have to be thinking about
these things. It's good. It's a good dog.
That's all. Yeah. I'm always very fearful.
Those beavers that shed at times
for three, this time around,
she knocks was coming here. If any
intention, let's put our heads together.
Thanks
Lucas.
Okay.
Be here a while for networking
and stuff like that.
So thank you very much with them.